le monde
à vingt cinq ans hubert beuve-méry s'en
va jacques fauvet lui succède
je ne crois pas que ce journal soit
ennuyeux ou alors il faudrait supposer
que les français aient un goût
particulier pour l'ennui puisqu'il tire
h et développer considérablement il a
doublé en dix ans je ne pense pas qu'un
journal ennuyeux aurait gagné autant de
lecteurs que le journal soit sérieux
s'efforce de l'être ça c'est davantage
vrai et c'est un hommage rendu aux
lecteurs que de s'intéresser en plus
grand nombre un journal sérieux qu'il
soit un peu triste pas sa présentation
un peu sévère un poster c'est vrai mais
chacun son style
et là encore je ne pense pas que le
lecteur nous en veuillent ce qui
peut-être davantage exact que la vérité
comme disait philosophe c'est triste est
que dans la mesure où nous tendons non
pas la vérité nous tendons à
l'objectivité
nous ne sommes pas un journal très
distrayant mais depuis des années nous
sommes efforcés de créer des rubriques
ou de développent des rubriques de
divertissement et là encore la tente du
lecteur était satisfaite et je ne pense
pas que le journal soit aussi austère
qu'on le dit ou que le disent ce qu'ils
ne lisent pas bien entendu le monde élus
essentiellement par l'écart moyen
supérieur du pays mis les nues par les
jeunes puisque nous avons là les la
clientèle la plus jeune de tous les
journaux parisiens puisque si j'ai bonne
mémoire plus du quart de nos lecteurs au
moins de 34 ans ce qui donne un
pourcentage élevé et il suffit de
circuler dans les rues ou même dans le
métro et quelquefois même dans la
wiesmann faire pour voir que ce ne sont
pas seulement de grands bourgeois ti
lisent le monde peut-être à l'origine
s'agissait-il une clientèle limitée à
une certaine catégorie de la population
aujourd'hui avec un tirage qui avoisine
500 mille exemplaires nous sommes tout
naturellement conduit à être lus par des
lecteurs de milieux de fort différent
alors le monde est-il une institution
l'a dit c'est peut être vrai ce qui est
sûr c'est que la démonstration vont être
faite car une institution vie où survit
indépendamment des hommes qui la servent
le départ la retraite de son fondateur
vont permettre la démonstration que le
monde est une institution
quant à moi je n'en doute pas et je
crois que la démonstration sera positive
c'est à dire qu'il y aura une continuité
du style du journal et du rôle du
journal alors les journalistes du monde
ne sont pas supérieurs aux autres
youri viennent quelquefois des autres
journaux où il y retourne
ils sont différents tout simplement
parce que chaque journal à sa vocation
le nôtre à la sienne et les journalistes
s'adaptent à cette vocation particulière
du journal du monde qui est une
institution dans la mesure où elle ne
dépend pas des événements du jeu des
forces puisque sa structure
institutionnelle précisément le met à
l'abri de toute influence politique
économique
en cela il est déjà une institution
juridiquement est structurellement les
136 journalistes du monde son
propriétaire de 40 % des actions du
journal
sans l'accord de la société des
rédacteurs aucune décision majeure comme
la nomination d'un nouveau patron ne
peut être prise cette idée assez
audacieuse intéresse beaucoup de
journalistes en france et à l'étranger
quand en 1951 ses adversaires politiques
ont tenté de prendre le contrôle du
journal est obligé de muri à
démissionner les journalistes ont refusé
son remplaçant ils ont sauvé le monde
est le directeur
si le mot n'est pas ennuyeux il n'est
pas non plus amusant jamais en vingt
cinq ans il ne daignant publié une seule
photo n'est parfois aujourd'hui il va
jusqu'à publier un dessin le monde a
autant de lecteurs en province qu'à
paris en lecture sur cinq se trouvent à
l'étranger critique et admiré influent
dérangeant nelu les lecteurs du monde
savent que beuve méry signe toujours ses
éditoriaux sérieuse s'il n'a pas choisi
ce nom de plume parce que sirius est la
plus brillante étoile
mais dit-il pour souligner toute la
distance qu'il y avait pendant
l'occupation allemande entre les
événements et ceux qui pouvaient en dire
monsieur chaban delmas en voit tous les
jours un moteur chercher son lot
d'exemplaires dès la sortie du journal
lettre comment lisez-vous le monde
oh c'est très simple je ne regarde pas
la première page je vais immédiatement
aux pages 8 des 9 qui concerne la
politique intérieure c'est la priorité
ensuite je reviens en arrière et je lis
la politique internationale après jolie
l'éditorial enfin à l'avant dernière
page je regarde cours de l'or non que
j'en ai mais parce que c'est un
thermomètre et enfin je vois à la
dernière page les nouvelles que l'on n'a
pas eu le temps de placer dans les
autres voilà comment je lis le monde
c'est parce qu'il est complet en somme
vous êtes un fervent d'acteurs du monde
absolument un admirateur à la le terme
est trop grand
parce qu'il faudrait un fervent lecteur
c'est certain je m'informe un admirateur
il faudrait y inclure la ligne politique
qui jadis plus encore que maintenant
nous sépare a vivement
alors là ce serait trop mettons que je
suis pour le monde que le monde est pour
moi une nécessité
merlet l'a fait que le monde était
contre l'algérie française et vous vous
étiez pour absolument le monde aurait
quand même été pour l'algérie française
si celle ci s'était sauvé elle-même
malheureusement elle n'a pas pu vous
avez participé à la création du monde
oui en 1944 et pouvez vous nous dire
comment ça s'est passé afin de comment
est né le monde
et bien moi j'ai été introduite dans la
société par des amis qui m'ont proposé
j'ai accepté et j'ai apporté ma modeste
part parce que les parents n'étaient pas
très élevées à 120
et alors on nous sommes réunis à 9
je crois bien que ses maîtres blancs
chez le notaire du monde et le 11
décembre une fin d'après midi d'hiver
et puis alors très peu de temps après il
ya eu la première réunion dans le fameux
bureau de du temps ils n'étaient pas si
beau qu'il est maintenant mais c'était
pas d'une affaire d'argent n'a jamais
été une affaire d'argent c'est ça qui
était beau c'est ça qui a fait la force
du journal
mais ce qu'on peut dire que le monde est
un journal un peu à gauche disons oui je
le crois je le crois je sais pas si
c'est le s'il doit dire ça mais moi pour
moi il est un peu repris et a peur c'est
même bien y aller j'ai des amis qui me
disait comment valider ce journal selon
al communiste autre forme que je dis
n'est pas communiste mais il est à
gauche
heureusement
monsieur veuve mary bonsoir merci d'être
venus et j'ajoute aussi bon anniversaire
puisque votre journal vos collaborateurs
ou même vous fêter le 25e anniversaire
du journal et de votre direction
si vous voulez bien parlons tout de
suite de vous et j'allais vous demandez
tout de suite comment vous baignez vous
vous même je vous demande cela parce que
j'ai lu dans l'express sous la plume de
jean-jacques servan-schreiber qui a
travaillé avec vous que vous étiez un
grand bonhomme
sous la plume de françois giroux que
vous étiez gracieux comme un cactus dans
combat ce matin que si les journalistes
français ont encore une fierté c'est à
vous qu ils le doivent
dans l'expansion de ce mois que vous
étiez alceste meneur d'hommes alors je
ne vous demande pas de choisir entre ces
formules plus ou moins agréables
je vous demande simplement votre propre
définition de vous même c'est une chose
à laquelle je n'ai jamais songé
je pense que quand on s'expose au
jugement du public et à plus forte
raison au jugement des confrères c'est à
eux d'avoir une opinion mais comment
pourrais-je me définir moi même moi je
voudrais tout simplement vous demandez
quelle idée avez vous du journal le
monde il me semble l'idée que sous une
forme ou une autre on devrait avoir de
tout journal si on veut qu'il fasse bien
son métier c'est-à-dire qu'ils
traduisent le plus correctement possible
la réalité des faits et qu'il donne le
plus d'éléments possibles pour les juger
c'est bien ça notre métier vous êtes
donc européen oui bien sûr je crois
l'avoir été depuis toujours mon premier
article 19 sans fin 32 tout à l'heure on
aurait pu croire que j'avais commencé à
faire du journalisme en 35 ou 36
en réalité je crois être un des sinon le
plus vieux bien sûr mais un des vieux
syndiqués au syndicat des journalistes
français ça doit remonter 1922 août 1923
se fait donc au moins 45 ans et que je
suis
inscrit dans la corporation et j'avais
fait en trente deux partir du moment où
je commençais à voir un peu ce qui se
passait en europe centrale
un article et qui était intitulé de
l'union danubienne à l'union européenne
à ce moment là il n'y avait pas
tellement d'amateurs je regrette par
exemple qu'un journal comme le monde
je rends je rends d'ailleurs hommage à
sa qualité technique et enfin un certain
nombre de ses qualités mais je regrette
qu'à ce moment là la voix de cyrillus
par exemple le soit pas élevé dès le
début pour dire que ces guerres étaient
des guerres perdues ç'aurait été de la
lys et de lucidité politique mais que
ces guerres étaient aussi des guerres
injustes et sorède et et de la morale
par exemple à propos des guerres
coloniales et notamment de la guerre
d'algérie il me semblait tout de même
que le parti communiste et même moritan
maurice thorez en personne n'était pas
tellement partisans de l'indépendance
algérienne journal inattendu dirigé par
hubert beuve méry directeur du journal
le monde où bientôt ex directeur puisque
vous avez choisi de prendre votre
retraite à 68 ans comment se fait il que
vous ayez pris cette retraite avec rage
pour les raisons les plus simples et les
plus normales la sécurité sociale
prévoit la retraite à 65 ans il me
semble que les décisions des décisions
importantes grave qui engage l'avenir
il vaut mieux qu'elles soient prises par
des gens qui auront à vivre cet avenir
et non pas par quelqu'un qui étant donné
son âge normalement échapperait
aux conséquences crois en effet que
certaine rigueur est nécessaire
une rigueur naturellement bien compris
plaisanterie on va ça finit par devenir
une plaisanterie au journal un peu une
manie du patron dans les débuts je me
référais souvent un texte de péguy qui
dit que le banc aux chaises
doit être bien frais non pas pour le
patron
on pas pour le client mais pour le
baroud shell en lui-même pour lui même
parce que c'est un barreau de chaise
[Musique]
on dit du monde qu'ils indépendant
honnête mais pas du tout objectif
qu'en pensez vous parce que il faudrait
se mettre d'accord une bonne foi sur le
sens du mot objectif si on prend comme
je crois qu'il est bon de le faire dans
toute sa rigueur
ça voudrait dire une parfaite conformité
entre l'objet où la personne est ce
qu'on en dit mais il est évident que
cela n'a jamais existé et
vraisemblablement n'existera jamais est
ce vrai que les général de groupe qui
vous a demandé de fonder en grand
journal il me l'a pas demandé à moins
mais il avait demandé à son gouvernement
est sans ministre de l'information de
l'aider à faire sortir un journal puis
naturellement dans sa pensée ne pouvait
être qu'un grand journal et s'était
heurté à toutes sortes de difficultés
vécues les plans et plus extravagants et
de proche en proche des choses sont
orientés vers moi parce que j'ai été un
ancien rédacteur diplomatique du temps
parce que j'avais donné ma démission du
journal au moment de munich parce que je
revenais du maquis enfin un ensemble de
circonstances qui faisaient que c'était
à part lui à certains comme eux lidoine
est-ce qu'on n'a jamais essayé de vous
faire taire bien sûr
quand on est obligé d'aborder de front
un problème aussi délicat que la guerre
d'algérie où la guerre d'indochine ou
des intérêts des sentiments souvent
infiniment respectable sont en
contradiction violente
on ne peut pas ne pas subir le
contrecoup de ses contradictions
alors bien sûr à certains moments nous
avons perdu des lecteurs
quant aux pressions du gouvernement
elles ont par moments été très fortes
sous la quatrième république sous la
vème république
et bien sûr nous n'étions pas toujours
ni même peut-être souvent d'accord avec
le gouvernement
je dois en tout cas rendre cette justice
au général de gaulle que s'il a
manifesté très souvent et très vivement
même son mécontentement
il n'y a jamais eu d'entreprise contre
le journal mais dans le ivème république
et il me semble je me souviens bien
on a même monté un journal le temps dans
l'espoir de boue ou faire descendre
oui faire taire oui bien sûr c'était le
temps de bari et ce n'était pas par
hasard que l'on avait repris ce mode
temps puisque nous avions succéder
autant en 44 le temps qui avait été
interdit de paraître pour des motifs
afin qu'ils n'étaient pas les vrais il y
en avait peut-être mais ce ne sont pas
ceux laquelle on a invoqué en tout cas
cette entreprise qui n'avait pas grand
chose de commun avec
le temps sauf que elle était financée
par un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises a connu un échec rapide
totale et très coûteux parce que c'était
la dernière fois qu'on a essayé de de se
débarrasser du monde
oui à partir de ce moment là et il s'est
créé à tort ou à raison une certaine
impression que nous devenions sinon
indestructible
en tout cas que il était décidément trop
cher de créer une concurrence valable
appréciable le monde est il un journal
de gauche c'est une grande et difficile
question je ne souviens que au début
pendant longtemps dans la presse
américaine
nous étions un journal lève texte puis
nous avons été un journal neutraliste
puis nous avons nous avons presque
toujours continuer de faire des progrès
nous avons été un journal indépendant et
puis ils feraient ans yom m'excuser je
parle l'anglais très mal le moins qu'on
puisse dire
et puis j'ai même vu des formules de
temps en temps arrivent les respectables
ça vous donne une en même temps un petit
schéma de l'évolution extérieur alors
dans tout ça est ce que nous sommes ou
non sur naldo gauche aurait tendance à
dire que nous sommes pour l'évolution
vers le programme qui se situent
généralement à la gauche s'il doit y
avoir un accélérateur dans certains cas
il doit aussi avoir
freins je ne néglige nullement le le
rôle de frein qui dans certains cas ne
doit pouvoir être le nôtre connaît pas
gaulliste je n'ai jamais été gaulliste
même pendant la guerre prêt si on entend
par gaulliste 7
cette adhésion totale à une personne
ce n'est pas une raison pour discuter ce
que général a pu faire de bien ou de mal
mais un jour nous parlions et où il me
faisait des reproches à propos de la
constitution et m'avait dit trop eu ce
jour là j'ai su que vous n'étiez pas des
miens évidemment dans ce sens là je n'ai
j'avais été dacia avec quels sont vos
origines ou mes origines sont très
modeste famille bretonne des deux
branches et ouvriers artisans tout petit
bourgeois si vous voulez à certains
égards mais ma mère veuve très tôt était
couturière et mais nous avons eu enfin
j'ai eu une une enfance très très pauvre
vous avez été si non pessimistes
réaliste mais vous voyez maintenant des
raisons d'optimisme
il y a toujours des raisons d'espérer et
de désespérer il faut garder des raisons
d'espérer prendre les autres comme un
défi qu'on accepte de relever si vous
voulez pendant la guerre je me souviens
d'une formule qui nous était arrivé à
devant un parachutage c'était un article
je crois de kessel qui était intitulé
pour une fraternité active des
pessimistes à court terme
c'est un peu compliqué mais je crois que
ça traduit ça doit traduire très bien
l'attitude qu'il faut avoir en face des
difficultés du moment et en gardant
l'optimisme plus long terme
[Musique]